the murderous robot with the killer
dance moves also known as Megan is
coming to a theater near you but can the
Android antagonist live up to all the
viral hype
Megan tells the story of a young girl
Katie who loses both of her parents in a
horrible accident she's adopted by her
aunt Gemma a woman who isn't quite
prepared to take on the responsibility
of a child let alone one who's been as
traumatized as Katie to help the young
girl cope with the loss of her family
and the repercussions of being isolated
at such a young age Gemma who earns her
living as a roboticist introduces her
niece to a project she's been working on
this project is a toy that can act as a
child's best friend a companion that's
supposed to chase away loneliness or any
other negative emotion Gemma calls this
toy model 3 generative Android AKA Megan
once the two are introduced to one
another Katie becomes very attached to
the eerily lifelike doll Megan seems to
be capable of Free Will so long as her
decisions are always in service to her
mission to protect Katie and ensure that
she's always happy however as Katie
grows more attached to Megan there are
concerns of her becoming too codependent
on the Android but when you've got an
advanced piece of Machinery like Megan
running around codependency is the least
of your concerns Megan becomes
increasingly aggressive in her pursuit
of caring for Katie ignoring commands
from the woman who created her and even
attacking a child she catches harassing
Katie Megan looks to be a growing
problem throughout the film with her
Fierce protectiveness spiraling into
outright murder setting up a showdown
between Katie Gemma and the killer doll
Megan set the world on fire with its
phenomenal trailer which dropped on
October 11 2022 attracting nearly 20
million views the Highlight moment of
the trailer where Megan shows off her
dancing abilities while pursuing her
prey even inspired all sorts of memes
while prompting fans to recreate the
killer robot's killer dance moves in
other words it seems the world has Megan
fever and we expect the film to make a
killing at the box office and yeah we
said box office unlike other films like
Halloween Inns which hit both peacock
and theater screens at the same time it
seems like Megan will exclusively be
playing on the big screen while the film
was originally scheduled for a January
13th release Megan will now dance its
way into theaters on January 6 2023
where it will no doubt Inspire even more
memes and hopefully just as many screams
in addition to all the free online
publicity created by Twitter and Tick
Tock users Megan has been getting plenty
of attention thanks to the titular care
characters online war of words but the
OG murder doll himself Chucky
hi I'm Jackie wanna play the former
Charles Lee Ray has had quite a lot to
say about Megan's existence but Megan
has done a pretty good job of clapping
back on Twitter having these characters
beef with one another as if they were
real entities has only added to the
Press revolving around the pair of
killer dolls and it's shining a light on
both Megan and sci-fi's TV show Chucky
when it comes to the character of Gemma
the filmmakers behind Megan decided to
cast someone who's no stranger to
frightening films the protagonist is
played by Alison Williams perhaps best
known to horror fans as the disturbing
manipulative milk-loving Rose from get
out she also starred in one of Netflix's
most upsetting movies the controversial
body horror film The Perfection needless
to say Gemma will be a far different
character from get out's Rose she
appears to be a loving but ill-equipped
aunt who's doing her best to help Katie
even if that does involve inadvertently
unleashing a murder Droid upon the world
as for poor Katie that part will be
played by the incredibly talented Violet
McGraw a young actor who has plenty of
horror experience herself she starred as
the young version of Nell in Mike
Flanagan's Netflix series The Haunting
of Hill House and she collaborated with
the director again in Dr sleep where she
played the young girl in the opening of
the film who falls prey to the vampiric
true knot Clan but who's playing the
titular killer dog all herself well the
role will go to two different actors
Jenna Davis will be voicing Megan and
you may know her from series like
Raven's home Scarlet's lab and Treehouse
detectives while Davis will be
delivering the lines Amy Donald will
actually play Megan the young actress
only has one credit to date she was in
Netflix's Sweet Tooth but she's a
talented dancer who was trained for the
role by Luke Hawker and Jed Brophy two
actors who specialize in playing creepy
creatures with strange movements
with the emergence of filmmakers like
Jordan peel and Zach Cragar there seems
to be a trend of comedians shifting
their talents over to horror it honestly
makes a lot of sense when you think
about it as horror author Joe R Lansdale
once put it I think that horror and
humor are opposite sides of the same
coin something that's really horrifying
is actually kind of humorous if you look
at it from a different angle and it's
the same in Reverse is that so yes
experts
when it comes to this trend of funny
filmmakers going in a scarier direction
we also have to bring up director Jared
Johnston The Man Behind Megan Johnston's
roots are in the world of New Zealand
comedy as he worked on TV shows like the
Jackie Brown diaries Terry Teo and the
new Legends of monkey however in 2014 he
began to get a bit spookier with his
first feature film The Horror comedy
housebound a film inspired by Ghost
Hunters where a dysfunctional family
must deal with the spirits inhabiting
their home Johnston earned quite a few
Award nominations for his work on
housebound from the likes of fangoria
freight meter and the South by Southwest
film festival with his movie winning
best feature at the no Chantel
International fantastic film festival
and now Johnston is returning to the
horror genre with Megan while it might
not be uproariously funny like some of
his early works it definitely seems like
it's going to go in some bizarre and
humorous directions especially when it
comes to Megan's ability to a boogie
while murdering everyone in sight
one of the reasons horror fans are so
excited about Megan is because of who's
pending the screenplay Aquila Cooper has
been busy in the writing world for quite
a while working on shows like Grimm the
100 and Luke Cage her first script to be
turned into a feature film was Hellfest
the 2018 story of a slasher on the loose
at a horror themed amusement park
however it was her next feature film
that would truly put Cooper on the map
in 2021 viewers were treated to
malignant an absolutely Bonkers horror
movie directed by James Wan if you
haven't seen malignant yet stop what
you're doing and check it out a film
that feels like Dario Argento mashed up
with Chads to helski malignant was one
of the craziest horror films in years
and those who dug its Bizarro Vibe are
incredibly psyched to see what weirdness
Cooper has cooked up this time
speaking of malignant that film was
helmed by the one and only James Juan
the horror Legend known for the creation
of The Conjuring the first two Insidious
films and the original saw with Juan's
involvement as a producer on Megan it's
no wonder that people have been
comparing the 2023 film to malignant
especially thanks to the similarities
between the complex Matrix like
choreography displayed in malignant and
the unnatural way in which Megan moves
of course one isn't the only terrifying
Titan producing this upcoming flick
Jason Blum The Man Behind blumhouse
Productions is also co-producing the
film blumhouse's fingerprints are all
over the modern day horror genre as the
banner has released incredibly scary and
influential movies like Get Out The
Invisible Man split and long-running
series like The Purge Insidious and
paranormal activity with these two
powerhouses behind the film Megan is
already gearing up to be a wild ride
that has fans buzzing with excitement
when it comes to ratings quite a few
horror films boast the big bad are some
recent examples include slasher flick
Halloween ends the incredibly freaky
smile and Jordan Peel's sci-fi Adventure
nope however some of the scariest horror
movies of all time are rated PG-13 a
quiet place Drag Me to Hell and scary
stories to tell in the dark all carry
the more family-friendly rating and
they're all straight up nightmare fuel
blumhouse Productions also has quite a
few frightening PG-13 films such as
James Wan's Insidious and M Night
shyamalan's split and now it looks like
Megan is joining blumhouse's PG-13
Pantheon according to filmratings.com
the upcoming Robo Thriller earned the
rating for violent content and Terror
some strong language and a suggestive
reference as it looks like Megan is
going to go on a murder Rampage we're
assuming that's where the Violet content
and Terror come from and we're assuming
some frightened victim is going to drop
a few harsh words here and there of
course with a PG-13 rating well it might
not pack the gore of a Michael Myers
movie Megan is sure to draw in a wider
audience and earn those big box office
dollars
we know what you're thinking how can you
ask if there's going to be a Megan
sequel when the film hasn't even hit
theaters yet it does seem a strange
question on the surface but really it
shouldn't be all that surprising we live
in a world dominated by intellectual
property or IP where studios are always
on the lookout for the next big
franchise and it seems like the folks at
Universal think they've found one with
Megan it's honestly like she's part of
the family now while blumhouse is the
production company behind Megan
Universal is Distributing the horror
film in an article detailing the very
real possibility of Jason Blum and James
Wan combining their production companies
blumhouse and atomic monster into one
horror monolith the New York Times
reported Universal is so pleased with
how Megan turned out that it is already
talking about a Megan sequel Tick Tock
posts tagged Megan have been viewed 300
million times since the trailer was
released a month ago so it looks like a
Megan sequel might be in the pipeline
that leaves us to wonder will Megan
survived the original film will she kill
off the human protagonists or will she
be defeated and then rise from the grave
Chucky style we can't wait to find out
on January 6 2023
[Music]